companies don't need two million dollars
or four million dollars to get started
anymore they
need a credit card and they need some
kutzler
and they need to go out there and and
start building something
[Music]
thank you so much for joining me on 20
minute leaders it's a pleasure to be
here thank you
so great to have you i can't wait to
learn so much as much as i can over
these next 20 minutes
you know i'm not going to be able to do
justice for all the incredible things
you've done but just
as a background you're running
illuminate ventures that i think you've
deployed over 100 million dollars
in incredible investments which i'd love
to hear a little bit about your
investment strategy there
fast company has cited you as one of the
most influential women in tech san
francisco business times
something similar and you're very
excited about women in tech in general
and you have and
one you have a widely cited paper called
high performance
entrepreneurs women in high tech okay
i've done my part cindy
talk to me a little bit about where you
come from how did you get started with
entrepreneurship
and let's roll into illuminate ventures
okay
love to um well your first question is a
good one because i come
from a very entrepreneurial family uh
my grandfather left eastern europe
built his own business in the united
states uh that was then
run by my father and uncle then by my
four siblings
and now by the fourth generation that's
involved in that business
so i grew up in that business i grew up
understanding what it meant
to have integrity i understood what hard
work was i understood what
working on weekends meant because i
would go into the office with my father
doing everything known to mankind and
uh so interestingly enough i assume from
day one
that i would do something
entrepreneurial in my life
but um i took an interesting circuitous
path to get there i had um
gave my uh mba at carnegie mellon i came
out of
there and actually joined the largest
corporation in
the world at the time and uh i started
really really big and learned what it
was like to
sell into large enterprises and all the
rest of that
my first job was actually a sales
position wow and
i i think that's one of the best jobs
you can have including
after you've got your mba because you
learn about
um how to overcome obstacles cindy i'm
sorry i'm i'm losing you a little bit
static early experience
i'm sorry i lost you can you go back to
that about what what
why and why the sales
is why having a sales position early on
is important
yeah i think what's really interesting
about having
an early role in your life in in sales
is that
you are constantly facing obstacles and
objections and you learn
how to overcome those you learn how to
deal with uh adversity you learn how to
deal when people say no
and and to move on and you know continue
feeling that you can still be successful
in spite of
one person perhaps one customer saying
no
i think those are skills and learnings
that are really really helpful
as an entrepreneur i've heard that quite
a few times i've heard quite a few times
actually that
that one of the most important things to
really hone in as
especially as young entrepreneurs to be
able to sell which is
so almost counterintuitive to what you
know i grew up learning is
selling is bad just build impactful
stuff and and the people will come to
you but
now i hear a lot of really incredible
people say that actually
having the the skill set of selling and
being able to communicate well
that's incredibly important yeah i think
sales is a really maligned
uh job and title in some companies like
i remember
uh when i was doing this and at ibm you
were they were called
marketers and i think that's not
marketing they're selling
um you know just face it admit it be
proud of it
and um and i was proud of it i was you
know
one of the the top uh 10 sales people
in uh an organization that had hundreds
of thousands of employees you were one
of the top
10 sales people at ibm uh at at 18t
wow unbelievable and i i was very proud
of that right
um and you had to work very hard to get
that and and
but it wasn't that i wanted to be a
sales person the rest of my life right
uh but what a great experience i mean
even after my mba
the training they put me through
included you know how to overcome
objections
how to communicate better with people it
helped me understand my own
style and how that uh could relate to
other people it was super helpful
and and it also you know took me down a
notch or two from time to time when
customers just said no
right well i'm guessing that to get to
the to get to the top ten you have a lot
of
yeses along with those no's so i'm
guessing that that that's pretty
incredible
okay so take me to illuminate ventures
and why are you running a venture firm
why are you investing in other
entrepreneurs having gone through your
path
that's a great question as well i i um i
had gotten to a point in my career where
i had
you know i'd been in a number of
startups i had founded my own
we had been fortunate to have that be
acquired by a public company and
i started working with some of my
friends in the venture community doing
roles that people today would call
venture partner operating partner kinds
of activities
and i had an amazing opportunity to work
with some
very respected investors i didn't start
doing that thinking i would become a vc
uh but over time i realized that
it was an amazing opportunity for me to
start applying skills
and experiences and
just knowledge sets that i had that i
had acquired over many many years and
and my network
i would say the network itself was
perhaps the most
important element of it i knew investors
because i had been out raising capital
for my own company
i knew entrepreneurs because i'd been in
several
entrepreneurial startups um and i also
knew people in the corporate world
customers business partners etc that i
could then
leverage those relationships to help a
whole series of founders rather than
just help myself
getting access into those and i suddenly
started discovering
that even though i had never set out to
do it i didn't have a finance degree i
had
a very quantitative mba from carnegie
mellon but i've
never been on that side of the equation
i believe you very recently gave
a commencement address right to the
school of engineering
i uh the master's program on the west
coast campus yes i had a really
great privilege and you know terrifying
to to do that because you're always
worried
oh no you don't want to mess up
someone's college graduation there you
go yeah
it was it was a great honor yes thanks
um
but in any case the um the opportunity
for me suddenly just was staring me
right in the face i i looked at it and i
said you know
why not create a portfolio versus invest
all of my time and energy in one company
um and why not start giving back into my
community that the things that i've
learned over
so many years and and experiences and
then i had the good fortune to be
invited to join one of those firms that
i was doing some projects with
i invested out of their fund for about
four years
um had an opportunity to build a track
record
but then 2008 came along and that was
super
interesting because the firm i was with
had
had offered me a full partnership they
were going to go out and raise
a new fund but i stood back and i
realized
how much the world had changed right
when i started
um my company a company called vivant
which was a sas services procurement
software company
uh the public cloud didn't yet exist
and so that was in
1999. wow so the internet is about
four or five years old really right
that's right um
no no no pre-aws that's for sure
right and yet there were companies that
were choosing
to move down the path of having a
recurring revenue model of building a
multi-tenant
architecture but we had to spend a lot
of money to do that we had to
buy all of those tools anyway we had to
spend hundreds of thousands of dollars
for an oracle database license
all sorts of servers and then we had to
pay to host everything at rackspace
so we created our own and that's what
every company then that wanted to do sas
had to do
um and then of course brilliant people
and
um you know came after that and that's
what i stood back
and realized my gosh i needed two
million dollars just to start my company
i needed to buy the servers and the
software and everything else wow
or you could write a single line of code
and from
2004 to 2008 i was investing um in
early stage companies but that was still
series a that wasn't c
there was no such word as a series seed
back then you had angels
and then you had series a and i looked
at it and i said this is just crazy
companies don't need two million dollars
or four million dollars to get started
anymore they
need a credit card and they need some
kutzler
and they need to go out there and and
start building something i love it
so that's what i started looking for and
i realized
that there weren't any seed stage funds
that were focused exclusively on
enterprise software
most of the um people starting funds
that were
at that point that you know they were
called micro vcs
most of those funds um were focused on
consumer internet because the people
came google or came out of uh some you
know
uh more a more consumer-centric kind of
a business
so crazy beans uh were taken
many of them i must have dosed myself
heavily because
in 2009 i you know right in the middle
of the financial crisis
i decided to launch illuminate to focus
on exclusively
seed stage enterprise investing so the
world is collapsing and you're starting
a new venture arm to
put to invest more money to spend more
money
[Laughter]
you know i started um the firm and i
launched it in 2009
um and i understood it at the time i was
at least smart enough to understand it
wasn't a great time to go out and raise
capital
so i started warehousing investments
using my own capital
and when i went to raise the first fund
it was small it was a proof of concept
fund and i basically contributed those
investments into that fund
and um they became what we now call our
spotlight fund
which we um did a one and done close in
in uh late 2011.
and then we closed our fund roman
numeral one
in 2013 and roman numeral two in 2017
i guess that was mid-2017 we started
investing from that fund and
uh my partner jennifer joined me just
about a year and a half ago now
and we'll go raise our third fund um
soon
incredible okay so so illuminate over
these past i guess
10 11 years how how have you noticed
this venture arm transition as you're
gaining more experience
as you're seeing you know hundreds or
thousands of companies
what what kind of earned secrets did you
gain over these years
what kind of secrets have i gained
earned secrets you know stuff that only
from experience you could really gain
yeah um i i think one of them
is to really spend your time
finding the people that you want to work
with um
more so than the technologies or the
products or even the markets
uh if i've learned one thing it's
that early stage investing is all about
the people
right all about the people and of course
you know there needs to be product
market fit eventually and all of those
other things
but if you've got the right team um you
have a
much much higher probability of success
not only that though you know some of
the companies that i've worked with i've
sat on the boards now
um at bright edge it's almost 11 years
and exactly before we took them public
and then they were acquired by vista
that was 10 years
wow and so you really better
at at minimum trust and respect
the people that you're going to invest
in um
because you may be working with them if
you're lucky for a very long time
that's the goal so have you ever
invested in a company that you didn't
necessarily believe in but you really
believed in the people
and you felt that these these people are
a good bet maybe the product is not but
i trust that they'll pivot if necessary
i don't think i i don't think so to be
really honest well i think that then
you're seeing a thousand deals a year or
something then
you're going to find a good combination
right we have the opportunity
to be very selective and and
entrepreneurs do as well
and you know we look for the fit you
look for the fit i love that okay talk
to me a little bit about women in tech
women entrepreneurs
i mean you started long before
you know 2020 when when you know things
things are looking up talk to me a
little bit about this
what you've noticed over the past few
decades as you're in technology
you know i don't have the the luxury of
living so long and
and knowing and and seeing these things
progress
i'm coming into a time in the workplace
where you know as far as i'm concerned
everything is equal
and and you know every vc that i talk to
has at least
one woman who is a founding member or
managing director so
talk to me a little bit about about what
what's happened over these past years
well um sure i'd be happy to so when i
when i wrote the
the first white paper which was back in
so 10 years ago it's kind of remarkable
i i was never
intending to invest only in women but i
did
know having um been a woman founder ceo
myself
that there were challenges that there
were some obstacles
that that women faced and other minority
groups as well not just women
of course that um that the typical white
male did not
and i thought it was important to try to
understand
are those obstacles self-imposed in some
cases
are they um pipeline issues as
many people always have suggested what
were the obstacles and
also try to understand well okay for
those women who did receive
funding who managed to somehow get to
that level what happened
how well did they perform was there
you know that the same level of
performance as men or less or more what
what did it look like so i um while i
was fundraising and doing investments
and everything else
i decided to do some research around all
of this
i ended up enlisting the help of two
masters students at carnegie mellon my
alma mater to work with me on it
and i ended up reading i think something
in the range of 600 existing research
reports talking to the professors that
were doing the research on campuses
around the country
of talking to vcs talking to women
who had founded venture capital firms
previously
that had in most cases frankly not been
successful because
they were funds that have focused
exclusively on women
and i was trying to understand what
happened why why didn't that work what
was wrong with with the strategies
and i learned so much it was pretty
overwhelming a lot of that is in that
paper if anyone wants to find it they
can go to our website and just go
to illuminate ventures or just
illuminate dot com slash white paper
that's a great domain by the way um but
we
you know it was it was a labor of love
and one where after i did the research
just to be honest i was never planning
to write a white paper
but i wanted the data for myself i
put it into a powerpoint i shared it
with my advisory board
at one of our advisory meetings and they
said well you have to write
white paper about this and i said uh
i don't write white people so you know
and
anyway they insisted i finally did it um
with some help uh from these students
and
uh we had a phenomenal reaction because
what we
found and what we discussed was the
really high performance of women when
they were funded
and the fact that so many more than ever
in the past were qualified
had the entrepreneurial skills had the
entrepreneurial desire
had the right training education work
experience everything
um and yet many of them not only weren't
being funded but when they were
it was at a smaller level of funding
than
um than the norm wow the typical so
uh it was an interesting paper it it um
then following that just 18 months ago
we published a new report
that focused more on gender differences
in existing entrepreneurs
and venture capitalists and we're right
now
finishing up our latest in this series i
guess
uh now now i guess i can call it a
series of unintentional white papers
uh that is focused on students uh and in
particular on
mba students and how they think about
entrepreneurship and venture capital
fascinating fascinating i mean
i mean and really these papers are sort
of considered a hallmark of
understanding
the gender differences in
entrepreneurship and venture capital
cindy you know i'd love to take your
take on to get your take on
entrepreneurship right before we started
this talk you were starting to tell me
how awesome it is to be able to be a
young entrepreneur today
you know make me feel good about me
being a young entrepreneur
so here's the reality it doesn't matter
if you're
young or old from a chronological
perspective
but if you are thinking
entrepreneurially if you are creative if
you are
innovative if you dare to take your
ideas and put them in front
of front of other people and risk
rejection risk them saying no
and gather that feedback and build
something meaningful from it
i'm not sure there's any better feeling
um that you can possibly have you mean
it's it's just so rewarding it's such an
exciting thing to be able to be
um an entrepreneur so you before you
mention the word chutzpah which is
quite possibly my favorite word ever eh
talk to me a little bit about hutzpah
what what what does that mean to you and
and why
why is that an integral part of being an
entrepreneur
yeah so some time ago someone asked me
what do you think is the definition of
an entrepreneur
and i said i think it's someone who's
able to
look at insurmountable obstacles
and choose consciously knowingly
to ignore them not stupidly
not you know not you know like
pretending they don't exist
but choosing to ignore them that's
clitzba
that's hutzpah being able to have um
the ability to put you know your
concerns and worries aside
and um take the opportunity to
put yourself you are you're really
putting yourself out there your ego is
out there
because it's your idea it's your product
um
and your energy that's going into it and
then being a great leader a strong
enough leader
to convey that to a whole team of people
the best people you can find that want
to follow you
in you know meeting that ambition
reaching that goal
uh that's more than hutzpah that's
leadership as well but it's it's the
combination of those two i think that
it can make for a great entrepreneur 100
i keep hearing that it takes you know it
takes somebody that
crazy to you know forego a good salary
as an engineer or something and decide
to you know go and and and
and run after a crazy idea that could
possibly
make the world a better place or change
the remove the needle in some way
but having to go through those obstacles
and you know more than just ignoring it
but actually tackling them and getting
excited every day tackling them
you know i i often talk to my wonderful
girlfriend about how excited we are
that we have people telling us that what
we're doing is not gonna succeed
or it's just not right and we get
excited by this feeling that yes we're
going against the crowd
we're going against what people are
telling us because we innately believe
that what we're doing is right and it's
gonna work
and even if we fail that's okay because
we're
just that excitement and the energy we
get all along
is just worth everything cindy what are
you really passionate about
today you wake up every day you look at
companies you're investing you're doing
all sorts of things
what what are you really excited about
oh my gosh you know i i think
that i i love the work that i do
i mean if it doesn't show i don't know
like how to explain that but
i love the fact that we have the
opportunity to build
long-term relationships with founders
you know i mentioned
two of the founders where i sat on their
boards for 10 years
that's a remarkable opportunity when i
stood
with the others on the floor of the new
york stock exchange and
my founders the original founders of
exactly were up there
on the balcony and ringing the bell i
started crying
you know i started crying and somebody
said to me well is
is it the money and i'm like never
forgotten
[Music]
a number of different things in um in
life and some of it
is how our lives are changing because of
the crisis that everyone is facing today
um the innovation that's coming out of
that
the heartfelt um
sympathy that that people are able to
share and express
and and and help one another in in times
like this
you see the best side of people right um
and how they step up i i yeah
i just think that you know work
will change how we all work how we all
learn is changing so rapidly
because of you know limitations being
and restrictions being placed on how we
can work together
and i think the innovation that is going
to come out of this is going to be
phenomenal i'm sorry i can't wait and
you you bring so much optimism into it i
love it
cindy right before we go i want to thank
you again for your time it's so generous
of you you have so much going on
and really i really appreciate you
taking the time for this i need
three words that you would use to
describe yourself and then i'm gonna let
you continue running this awesome
venture
wow um i would say entrepreneurial yes
uh i would say i get to use two words
for some of these high integrity
okay and um
yeah passionate i love it
entrepreneurial high integrity and
passionate cindy
thank you very much i didn't i wanted to
also talk about j ventures that we're
both a part of
we didn't get to that but but i i look
forward to learning with you on our work
through the fund and thank you for all
the support and uh
and yeah good luck with everything and
and i can't wait to see this optimism
play out in real life
in the years to come thank you so much
michael
take care bye-bye
you